i believe
that
when my country calls for me
[Music]
that i should answer
[Music]
and the uh
oath that i thought
[Music]
is perpetual
it never ends
and i believe that i'm patriotic enough
that today
if something happened broke out and i
you would give me the m1 i had
i would stand inspired until i fell
that's the way i feel about my country
i love my country
[Music]
everybody remembers world war ii
everybody remembers vietnam
everybody remembers so many wars in
which americans have fought
except for one it's called the forgotten
war that would be the korean war which
began on june 25th
1950 and it is my true honor to be
joined by two american veterans of the
korean war a dale winston riggs and gw
brown
mr brown mr riggs thank you so much for
for making the track all the way to the
studio and joining us on what is the
72nd anniversary of the war never know
we make hollywood did you
[Laughter]
it is so wonderful to to have you both
here uh we've got uh dale i believe
that's your purple heart
from the war over there
uh
because people
do not really remember this conflict and
there are maybe lots of reasons as to
why
people don't remember that conflict
could you just begin by maybe telling us
what the korean war was for people who
fought it saw it firsthand in the
beginning of the war when
uh however shipped to korea
they neither had clothing that was
adequate
uh to keep you warm they didn't have
uh insulated
boots
and thick socks to keep you warm a lot
of
of our people lost the tips of their
nose and bottom parts of their ears
their
parts of their fingers from being frozen
that's something that is uh never was
published the american people never knew
about that
and it was way on up into 1950
before they
received adequate clothing
and of course
that was naturally
uh broadcast by the stars and stripes
so uh
the beginning of the war was uh
kind of tough because we were not
equipped or we were not
knowledgeable of the
of the extreme coal
it was it was
uh not unusual to be 30 below zero in
the mountains
and
that was
the outfit that i was in
we had to
go into the mountain range and stay in
the mountain range
and then you had those in the valley
and then you had those in the mountain
range on this side
we stayed in the mountains and i stayed
in the mountains 10 months
within that 10 months
i myself and my comrades that were in
the mountain range
we received clean clothes twice in 10
months
and they set up a huge
attempt to have baths where we could
take a bath and get new underwear and
new clothes and go on our way
and
just general things like that that the
general public
didn't know anything about
and
perhaps didn't care i really don't know
but the
the korean war was a miserable war
everyone that you will talk to will tell
you
that it was extremely cold
and and it was really hard to
stay in those mountains
and i soon learned that the only way
that i could save my feet
is that i would
come when i came to a stream
i would wash my socks out
put them around my waist and dry them
and where i would have clean socks
because you sweat
climbing those mountains and things like
that
we come offline and
and about three miles back they had a
tent set up and
we could go and take a shower outside
it was probably below zero wow jesus
you ever run through a shower
not below zero yes
then we run through the shower and then
grab some
big piles of clothes you just started
grabbing anything that you put on and
put on
yeah
the only uh
the only
uniform or the only yeah the uniform i
got was when we're not r r japan they
give us they really tailored us to make
so we didn't look like a bunch of bombs
man i'm telling you that we're living
rna japan i'm telling you that like
going to heaven
the way you're describing the the sheer
physical misery of this war you know not
adequately uh outfitted
you were both extremely young men at the
time yes yeah 17
17 could you even enlist at 17
yeah wow i i would assume it would be 18
or something no 17
wow father's father and mother had to
sign so i get into 17.
six of us all enlisted in the service
six my brother me and my brother at 17
we all enlisted at 17.
what impelled you to do it was it just a
patriotic call was it a desire to go see
the mountains of korea
just out of the hometown i'll put it
this way
the first time i had your own bed sleep
all alone
your own clothes
three hot meals a day
if you were lucky
if you can eat them yeah and then i get
sent down record and then for a bit i
asked your basic i was sent down to fort
jackson south carolina
and that is
i'll put it this way
korea was uh
a lot better in columbia south carolina
they hated us let me tell you in 1950
the rebels hated us with a passion
they hated the the northerners they
hated all of us yankees yeah
when we went into town there was only
one
restaurant or bar that we could go in
they'd be
down by the railroad station
that served their
servicemen
the rest of them we weren't allowed in
believe it or not
that's amazing to think you got a a
warmer reception in korea than
you would have in
in the southern states
you know the japanese the japanese
really like this
the japanese people really like this of
course the american soldier when they
got there from 45 jesus japan was
starving to that you know they had
nothing korea was the same way and the
american servicemen
supported that country they brought
these people up well because i mean this
is important historical context you've
got the second world war ending in 45
japan has been devastated shortly
thereafter you've got people starving
you've got people eating out of trash
cans in japan
and
i guess part of my confusion with the
korean war is this is a major conflict i
think it's something like 1.8 million
americans serve in korea at the during
those three years of the war or four
years of the war i guess
you've got
37 000 deaths of american
servicemen
it's not really talked about very much
and you think the united states has just
won the second world war we're now the
dominant superpower in the world we're
about to become the richest nation ever
why couldn't the american government get
you guys uniforms why couldn't the
american government uh spend a little
bit more money on this conflict well it
was still being rebuilt the country is
still being rebuilt
and the military
still today the military is reached
second we got to take care of the
politicians first in the military
believe it or not
them greedy bastards in washington
living high off the hog on your in my
money yeah yeah that's certainly true
well i was in europe two years before
the war broke out
um
and you asked the question what prompted
us to
uh go to go to the war
uh
i was very emotional and i when i took
the oath to defend
our enemies both
foreign and domestic
and to defend the constitution of the
united states
and to me that
that earth was perpetual
and
i don't want to sound like
some unsung hero
but i would not hesitate
to stand today with a rifle and fire
until i fall
simply because i believe the oath was
right
and it's never ending
me being in the army two years before
the war broke out
they
sucked all the people out of germany
that's where i was and they just
put us back here
and i was here i think
three four five months
and then i went to korea
in the latter part of 1950
and then i was at home in the latter
part of 1960
because they had began to talk
uh
peace
i may have heard a mistake here
in
1951 i was talking i made a mistake
about but anyway that is the uh
that is the reason i was in the korean
war
and
we encountered
many things that
the public never heard about the uh
the ignorance in many of the officers
that we had
knew nothing about fighting a war
and they got a lot of people
unnecessarily killed
because they failed to
have the proper training or to use the
proper weapons
i was
i went up and ranked fast i'm a sergeant
first class with sevilla
e7 and i was ordered to take out a
machine gun nice
when we had a
bazooka
laying on the ground here
in one round from a bazooka there would
be no more
but instead i lost half of my men
knocking out a machine gun dust
and i lost my medic he's a medic i lost
my medic
and they brought him out and
laid him up like stacked a black block
like you would
a row of uh
of logs or something
and and and very very very heartbreaking
in that process of knocking out the
shield machine gun
is when i was hit with a concussion
japanese
chinese grenade
and i was
unconscious for
between 13 and 18 hours that i didn't i
was i woke up in a field hospital
just
things like that that is never reached
pentagon or wherever it's supposed to be
the ignorance of some of the officers
and
since that time of course
over a period of 60 years i had i
finally had to go get counseling because
the
the
how should i say it the
the ptsd began to come out in a bad way
so i just so i went four months of
counseling
and had a very good counselor and it was
helped
tremendously
how to process
what had gone on without being hostile
about it
and things of that nature
did the the ptsd present itself
consistently after you got home from the
war or was it something
it
it was consistently and i
felt that uh
that i was too macho
to uh ask for help
we have got
thousands of
of the people out there that are
homeless that are
in
shelters they're in
nursing homes and things like that
and and they're suffering greatly from
ptsd
and there's help for them they have a
specific program for that
in the va hospital
that that ward is dedicated
specifically before
the ptsd
when you're talking about what just one
of these incidents you know they could
have used the bazooka and it would have
it would have saved half the men
do you think that that decision
just owes to the incompetence of the
officers or a lack of training on the
part of the political leaders or i would
hate to think that someone would
intentionally try to take lives so i
would have to opt for
the lack of training
because there were questions you know in
uh in terms of the politics of the
korean war
i i've always wondered if part of the
reason we don't talk about it as much is
because of the political controversies
the war begins under truman then it
shifts to dwight eisenhower before
truman leaves he infamously or famously
fires general macarthur
what is your take having actually been
there on on what the politics meant for
the war would you say it was a mistake
to to fire macarthur
biggest mistake in history
truman truman
didn't come around and say but truman
admitted
on the sly that and he
of course he fired macarthur strictly on
that bunch of chair warmers that he had
in washington
how do you think the war might have
turned out differently had macarthur
remained in command
he didn't want a truce he wanted
you either win the war or he made some
mistakes
by he he
he just went up the valleys and he
bypassed
all the chinese and north koreans in the
woods
and they closed in behind him
so we had to fight our way all the way
back
across the 38th parallel because we were
in their territory we went all the way
to the yellow river
this is a
this was known by many people but it was
not broadcast now i used to live next
door to colonel brown
which was the chief of staff at the
at the
white house
and
and he told me
that macarthur had ordered
four nuclear warheads for china
that he owed one for manchuria
and they had one for north
korea and
and they was in the plane
and that's why
truman fired him
because truman made an oath
in after dropping the bomb on on in
japan in world war ii
he made a note that as long as he was
had anything to do with
there would never be another nuclear
warhead used
now that's that is how close
it come from the war being ended in 30
minutes
instead of drugging out four or five
years because the the way that the war
worked is at after the second world war
korea had been
basically a colony of japan so all of a
sudden now korea is open japan's been
defeated and the soviets and the
americans basically divided up and the
communists have influence in north korea
the americans have influence in south
korea along the 38th parallel so the war
begins
with that divide on the 38th parallel
and i
after all these years of fighting after
37 000 americans die after 1.8 million
americans serve
the war ends on the 38th parallel it
ends up exactly the same
they have people on this side with guns
pointed that way people on the other
side with guns ported this way
now
well i i don't want wanna i'm not a
political person
uh
i don't know what mr
uh trump and
the fat boy did excuse the language
i think that's his official title is uh
kim jong-un the fat boy right
so i don't know what they talked about i
don't know what they accomplished but
apparently not very much because he's
still rattling his sabers now
to me if you give him a little money
he'll be quiet
that's what he's after but
uh for him to uh
to be a north korean
and look at how his people is treated
and look at how his country is
just generally nothing
and everything that he has has gone to
uh
war equipment and
they say he's got a
3 million man army
okay
a thousand of them are ladies
okay what are you going to do
if you've got 3 million
people on the ground ready to fight
and here comes the airplanes
so it it his three million people means
absolutely zero
as far as
being a threat to anyone else
that's my opinion now
the old dad was a little bit uh
different he would rather save her you
gave him money you'd be quiet but that's
that that's a political thing and you
you raise this interesting point too
which is north korea has a nuclear
weapon
now i don't know how effective their
nuclear weapons are uh donald trump had
that great line he said uh i have a
nuclear button too and mine works uh so
but but nevertheless north korea has
that nuclear weapon so
in your opinion having been on on the
ground there fighting
would would it have been better for the
war and for the country and for the
world had
perhaps the united states used a nuclear
weapon or had macarthur been permitted
to go further beyond the 38th parallel
maybe into china
do you think a more aggressive stance in
the war would have would have put the
world in a better position well i
consider myself a christian gentleman
southern christians and women
and i have my philosophies about war
if if if i have a country and it is
thriving and i'm the head of that
country
and you come at me you come at me at
your risk
i i don't believe in war i don't think
there should ever be another war i think
we ought to negotiate it out somewhere
another not ever have another war but
that's not possible
i think that we'll have other wars and i
think probably in short order
uh that's my opinion again
but
if you're going to win a war
you've got to go to war yeah
that's why they fired macarthur
he wanted to win yeah
washington didn't want that washington
was making money these bigwigs were
making money and i was fighting in korea
they were making big money
and they're still making big money on
our kids today so you're saying the
incentive would have been
just to prolong a kind of stalemate
rather than to actually go in and win
the war
that war wouldn't lasted three months if
they'd let us
so the war
goes on and on and it ends almost
exactly as it begins right there on the
38th parallel
do you think
it earned this
deserved title the forgotten war why do
you think people
talk about world war ii they talk about
vietnam and for for whatever reason
korea
is this blank spot in our history
it was too close to world war ii
people were just getting over
the effects of world war ii and then
korea showed up
and it was a country
country that they never heard of the
people we never knew
suddenly we were there
today the only people that really
appreciate what we did in korea
the the old south korean people
now i remember
in washington and all of our
honor flights and everything and meet
the
older koreans and
christ they're
hugging and kissing on you you know
today these you
it's hard to say to the american people
the soldier walking down the street
today the people almost telling him and
sailors and dogs keep off the lawn
that's the american people today
whereas the uh
south koreans certainly of uh 70 years
ago you know
god's among men still today south korea
still thinks the american soldier is god
you can't believe the conditions of the
uh the people
of south korea
uh when we went there
they had
zero zero sanitary facilities
they went on the ground or wherever and
used human waste for fertilizer
they they were
they were a very primitive people
when when we went there the housing
would be a
uh uh sort of a
of a teepee like an indian with
a little coke in there for a heater
and
they would stoke
just enough for a heater and what kept
them from freezing dead i have no idea
right
because it is so extremely cold over
there
but i want to mention one of the divine
delightful things about the south
koreans
they're here now and and
not in big numbers
but they're here and they're in business
and they're the most skilled people
that you ever want to deal with in the
building industry
that i was in for 58 years
i know about quality and they are
quality
people that's one of the divided
delightful things
but if you but if you go back
if you go back to korea
and and you you get a picture of south
korea
then
and get a picture of south korea today i
have a book
a nation reborn
south korea looks to me like hong kong
super high raised big huge tall office
buildings
uh neon lights i don't know why asia
goes for so much vietnam lights but they
love those neon lights in in
in the nation has been reborn because
they was willing to work
and they was willing to take the money
that the u.s
gave them and various other countries
i'm sure had chipped in and rebuild
their country
contrary to north korea
right it is still devastated there's
no roads
nothing nothing unusual to see a hundred
vehicles one day on a gravel on a dirt
road not even having gravel on a dirt
road
so
it's an entirely different
two countries now now the the american
involvement in korea was obviously great
for korea as you're describing that's
the reason south korea exists as we know
it today
what about the counter-historical
of if the united states just didn't get
involved in korea you know it was it was
part of the strategy of containment they
wanted to contain communism from
spreading around the world
what would have happened had we just not
gotten involved well it would have been
a communist nation
it's still better put it this way
the picture of north a pitcher of korea
and if you really want to see korea take
take look at a picture of korea at night
south korea is nothing but lights north
korea is light light light
six or eight places lights
their people are still the most backward
people in the world
and they're not being
brought ahead because
the military dictatorship don't want
them
they don't want them to know what's
going on and what's good for them and
what you know
well
they got them right in the palm of their
hand and they're holding them down
that's what it is
south korea is free
strictly
due to the american intervention
and that's probably the only country in
the world think the american soldier is
the greatest thing a gift to god
you you had mentioned earlier that now
in large parts of america
you know soldiers sailors and dogs get
off the lawn you know there's a lot of
come from world war ii with columbia
that's south carolina yeah
well i
why do you think that is i mean why do
you think we're at a spot in america now
where servicemen are are
not respected
well i'll put it this way and the minute
the bullets stop
forget it yeah politics take over
and you gotta remember these boys in
washington and girls they're they're
feathering their own nest first
well in my
i've never been disrespected
not not in in that once in my life i
don't know whether it's because i'm big
and ugly or and they was afraid or what
but nevertheless i've never been
disrespected
many many times and
even now
people pick up my lunch i don't have a
clue who they are
i can't thank them because i don't know
who they are
the
the korean war
and i i really don't know how to put
this
together
other than to tell you that the korean
war was a political war
strictly politically and am i right
strictly political political war and and
and uh
there was a lot of money put in korea by
the u.s the very few people helped
and
and and then
by being the political warriors it was
china
saw the opportunity
that they could send thousands and
thousands of troops in there and they
could overpower us and then they could
capture
both koreas
and they would have another communist
nation
but we were a little bit tougher than
they thought they were they thought we
were
and they couldn't get rid of us
so then after
chinese losing
way way younger bigger number than we
did
they decided that they would pull back
and take another look and that's when
they begin to talk about
a
cease fire now that's all they ever had
as a ceasefire the korean war as far as
i know has never ended right because
there's never been a surrender
so anyone that served in the korean war
from 70 years ago today
is a veteran yeah
he's a korean veteran huh
that's right because
at least
that's right at least officially the war
is still going on okay and and in those
those three
years you know of the before the the
armistice
the the the war was really a proxy war
right between the united states and
china and
the soviet union
so
you had american soldiers fighting
against the chinese
and fighting against russians at least
russians who were in covert operations
yeah so this could have been
you know in in these early years of the
cold war this could have been
led to a direct conflict between the u.s
and know in fact if the air force will
tell you the truth it's a known fact
that uh our fighter planes
in fighting their fighter planes they
weren't talking chinese they were
talking russian yeah
so you had because for for the cold war
the the official story is that the us
and and russia never got into a direct
conflict with one another but in korea
you had russian pilots
fighting at our pilot or shooting at our
pilots rather and you had russian
russian generals one of them was
captured and uh
one russian general was captured there
in their in their retreat
well they tried to they hushed that up
now now what do you make of what that
means for today i mean in the last few
years
the way that we've talked about russia
it seems as though the cold war never
ended russia rose and fall and fell
the communist the communist nation fell
in russia
and now uh you have a a
a man there that is spewing out
threatenings of
uh nuclear war and things like that
uh
in my opinion
there's
probably very few people have
any clue as to what you're talking about
when you drop a nuclear warhead
i mean it it's not a firecracker yeah
this man talking about doing
it it's it's
well it's just stupid
it's stupid
but he is bringing
i think part of the communist party
as as as what you call
staff
and they're keeping that alive but
that doesn't have anything to do with
korea but that was the
the aim behind
them being involved in the korean war
was to capture both koreas and make them
a communist country when you say it was
a political war
what exactly do you mean by that
it would be hard for me to explain i
i think number one that
mr truman should not have gone on over
there in the first place
that's my opinion
i felt he would think i think he was
obligated because
uh
state uh south korea stated that he was
a free nation
and that he did not want communists to
spread
which is political right and and uh
and then
when
when the korean war began to wane a
little bit
and then mr eisenhower come aboard
then
he saw a way to stop it almost
immediately now it doesn't mean that
after he
got a cease fire ceasefire they didn't
quit
there was many many gorillas that came
in
and fired on our troops and things like
that
and
and that happened many many times after
the ceasefire had been
agreed on
but
mr eisenhower
found a way to get rid of that and get
that calm down and get that settled
in the korean war then
it's forgotten
would you uh
agree with that assessment
churchill led him right around by the
nose
he'd let him around in world war ii by
the nose and he let him in korea
the the poor old veteran and i'm not i'm
not having a pity party and i don't want
to have a pity party
the poor veteran he carried the
pack on his back
and he gave
everything that he had to end that war
he's entitled to the fir to the same
respect
as world war ii or world war one
or any other wars
it's the same kind of fighting it's that
we use the same village we use the same
rifles
and the same the same
boys bled and died which
which is a bigger shame than we ought to
be able to stand
four wars one two korea and vietnam
the military
done the best they could do to win the
war and the politicians done the best
they could do to lose it for us that's
right right
you know in terms of that political
shift was it a
was it an improvement for the war when
truman was out of there and eisenhower
got in was it
was it not as marked was it yeah
yeah
i liked mr truman
i i i served under him in europe
and then i turned around and served
under him in korea
so i certainly served under him under
two continents
and i liked him i thought he was a great
guy
but he was
he was a great farmer
he knew how to grow things he knew how
to hold on to property
and and he didn't have a whole lot when
he went out of the white house
when truman left the white house
you know how much he was getting a year
for his uh living on 26 000
wow huh
truman didn't leave the the white house
rich he was very you know he was a hard
worker very poor i i read somewhere that
he he actually drove himself away from
the white house got in a car and drove
back to missouri
well the thing of it is and see the bad
feature
the military didn't own truman
they owned eisenhower right from the
shoes to the top of his head they owned
him
they didn't own truman he told them
exactly
when he said the buck stops here he
meant it the buck stops here
if i say yes we go if i say no we don't
eisner were led around by the nose i
put it this way i have no uh
great affection for eisenhower
well i don't have the occasion to shake
hands twice with eisenhower
one on one content one on the other
but uh he was yeah he
he was he was an everyday guy
and and and
a lot of things went on
that he wrote and he
did he actually put into operation
back before truman
right before truman ever come in office
he was influential
and and and some very important things
yeah he was and the chief you know the
chief of staff in the army eisenhower
was in with all of them people before
he get into a
combat situations so he was strictly uh
a political general
one of the things that you look at the
generals
and and and the high-ranking officers
okay
when the war is over
they're over
so eisenhower spent a lot of his years
at panama canal
doing odd jobs of
uh uh of people that you would think
that a sergeant should be doing
but nevertheless he
he spent his time doing that and then
when the wars comes on he's important
yeah
he's very important
general the army general the army is the
highest ranking of the nation
he's the head answer
right there's uh
yeah well what was the line from
macarthur s
uh sold marines don't die they just fade
away or what was like a soldier old
soldier never died yeah you're right
straight away
he's right
macarthur was a
i can't
of a jupiter he was probably
macarthur was a genius
without a doubt he was a military and
genius
and i only wish we had somebody like him
today
there's no ladies around
no yeah there is okay i was going to
tell the story but i won't do that oh
please uh we we can have them close
their ears and mixed company
well
when we went into korea
and we just went up the valley
to the yellow river
all the
anybody was out in the woods on the side
i guess laughing at us as we were doing
that
when we got to the yellow river
the manchurians on the other side
was mixed with the grill firing back at
us and bullets knocking up
in the mud and he was just standing
there
looking
in and the radio crackled always because
she already had her i always have a
radio man beside of him
matter of fact you have a backup
beside of him
and they wanted to report his
the uh
the condition of the war
and they said well we are at
the euro river
and we haven't had any
activity
they said well give us the number of
casualties he said we don't have it we
don't have any casualties
every swing and dick is here
[Laughter]
and
by that our our battalion yeah they
nicknamed them right the the swing index
yes
but it was never of course not it was
never put in the paper but that's what
we recall that is the best nickname i
have ever heard that is really really
that's something to be proud of
but then it was amazing when you turn
around
from where you just come from and you
turn around
and you've got several miles
of north korean
territory that you've covered right and
you've got to fight all the way back to
the 38th parallel
to get to where you're supposed to be
and that's where a lot of our loss of we
lost a lot of men that time you see the
38th apparel covers the entire across
the country
dividing south korea north korea
and that's where
most of my time was spent
uh
below the 38th parallel
and of course keeping the north koreans
and the chinese and stuff like that from
crossing that parallel that's what our
job was so i was spread back in the
mountains we had some of your spread
back in the mountains then we had people
down here with tanks and airplanes you
can't you can't take those of the
mountain right no vehicles in the
mountains
you know i mean nothing you if if
we climbed i i reclined to where i think
it would be hard for a squirrel to climb
do you think that the terrain was the
terrain was so controlling so rough yeah
so rough and and uh all our equipment
was carried on our back
it ain't like vietnam the trucks all
like the trucks come here and for the
next eight ten miles it was right on our
back
you carried everything you your your
food your weapons
your ammo
then we were lucky we had the chohis the
old korean uh
the old korean men that
come on their own and started carrying
all their supplies up to us
that they would just sort of volunteer
too
we're talking many
some of these guys were our age huh
they were young men they were all old
men and they were all volunteers to come
when i was a young man and just
into the korean war
i think i was a corporal at that time
we were sent out on
a
on patrol
to
make contact with the enemy
we really made contact then we
turned around and went back to our
outfit
so i had eight men
and
we
made contact closer than we wanted to be
because we didn't see them in time and
fortunately they didn't see us
so
i had a another young man his name was
brown
and he uh
he froze
he froze just
couldn't move he couldn't function at
all
just out of shock and i was shocked
and so i put him across my shoulder
and carried him about two miles
and he it was several hours before that
he could even
any kind of function
it's very hard for me as a civilian to
even
imagine that that you could be so struck
in in shock at seeing the enemy that you
you have to be thrown over a shoulder
and carried out it happens many times it
happens many times
and in two you talk about
you don't get very much hot food in
combat most of those russians
occasionally the cooks and fish fixed
your hot meal and we do when they do is
appreciated well they had pancakes and
eggs and bacon when the guy got by the
best i've ever eaten my life yeah
i believe that yeah
i remember my first meal back oh jesus
right
today these kids
they wouldn't even attempt to eat it but
we were eating
it was not the fanciest most elaborate
meal i imagine
no
but after looking
me
i've been i've traveled all over the
united states
in several foreign countries
and the people that i have met
and talked to about the korean war
i have yet to find one
to criticize the
military people that was in that war
i found it that
that i believe i have already said
that i i i have been respected greatly
and and and and people walk up to me and
thank me for
my service that means a whole lot yeah
so they don't i mean these are people
that wouldn't even born then
and and and and for them to be mindful
of that
is really
heartwarming
but
the thing
the country hadn't completely rebuilt
itself after world war ii remember five
years and it was still rebuilding itself
then suddenly we're
into another
as they call it a conflict yeah yeah
that's right they couldn't call it a war
because there was no official
declaration
one newsman was talking he says a
conflict i said just a minute
[Applause]
you're getting your ass shut off
it's not a conflict anymore it's a war
on the other side of the world
right right outside of the world yeah
and i i thank god
the american people don't
don't have to go through that i oh
do you think that is part of the reason
that
korea was not and is not talked about as
much as just that politically you know
coming right off of world war ii
they the establishment knew that the
american people did not want they didn't
want it they didn't tell them they
didn't tell them about that
they were still getting over world war
ii so they didn't want to tell them that
hey we got your kids into another one
you're right and just like vietnam
well there's there's been
so many fortunes made out of world war
ii
by people writing books
that don't have one eye out of
what they're talking about yeah
but but they they make it sound as
though they're right there and they've
got a rifle and they're firing with you
but it's not like that yeah do you think
that there are some misconceptions about
the war that have come out in these
books and
reports
they could have had that could have made
them have uh misconceptions because they
dramatized all they dramatized almost
everything
i doubt i doubt that you
well i find out that you could find a
book that is written that you can't go
in there
and you'll you you'll either find
somebody in there writing that that you
know about yeah now i i like mcdowell
i mean i'm really more i'm an early
american history guy i like my dao
and i read his books and there they
become
they're more accurate than any i have
ever read
from 1776 on yeah
is there a
it's interesting you mentioned that and
it's good to hear that you you've never
been disrespected ever since you came
back from the war in the in the same way
that say the vietnam veterans were
disrespected broadly when they came back
but there is this kind of a strange
procession here the world war ii
veterans
perhaps the most celebrated veterans in
the history of our country the greatest
generation greatest generation
then
the vietnam veterans completely
disrespected probably the most
disrespected of any veterans in our
country
and there's
the korean veterans right in the middle
mostly ignored
mostly
forgotten about
it's a strange progression there
i was uh
fresh out of korea
and then the vietnam war started
i had two children by that time so and
i'd already spent a tour in europe and
touring chris i wasn't worried about
being drafted
so i enrolled in school i was going to
school
but in the last 10 years
i've been involved
with
talking and counseling
and being with the vietnam people
and the vietnam people didn't do
anything wrong
they came back here and our own people
spat on them yeah
they didn't deserve that
i i thought maybe you know in the early
early part i thought well they're just a
bunch
just a bunch of dope heads yeah no but
that's not true
that's not true
they deserve far better than what they
received
well there was this group they called
them the baby killers and of course then
the press got it and
it was strictly political
but why do you think that shift occurred
just the craziness of the 60s and the
cultural revolution
maybe just sell more papers yeah
well it goes back to
stamping out communism
just about every war that we've had
goes to stamping out the communism
and korea was one more
political it was
communism versus
freedom
so uh
we want out and communism is not there
however it is above the 38th parallel
now the communists in russia is gone
uh
i don't know how long it'll take before
china sinks
right as long as she's got us to make
money off of i don't think she'll say
they're right we're we're funding the
regime at this point right yeah well put
it this way uh the amer america is
keeping common
communist china going
yeah right
right everybody they produce all of our
goods they buy up all of our debts right
if we could buy in
chinese goods in one year there wouldn't
be any china
although we wouldn't have any goods i
guess of that we wouldn't have anything
well do you have any specifics questions
you want to ask me yes there i would
like to ask about your specific
uh experiences of the war i mean for
instance you you and dale were a medic
so how you know how how does that differ
how does the experience of going out as
a medic differ from see
world war ii and then korea
medic was a
part of the
company the presume well today their
guys are trained to be their own medics
and everything else but
like i say i was trained as a medic for
in a rifle company well it does it does
seem like a
it's a it's got to be an emotionally
very taxing job too if you're just
constantly
on the line there with people who have
been injured or a death store perhaps
see i beg for it when i get in the army
i've done everything they first first
they put me into a medical unit
then as an ambulance driver and then as
a medic and i'd done everything in my
power finding it over she got me to
japan i finally wiggled my way to go to
korea
never did forget a way to get back
what what was it but it was uh you went
from 17 to 40 overnight you grew up
overnight yeah
that's my daughter asked me that said
what's it like i said well you went from
a boy to a man overnight
minute you heard that first bullet you
you were a man did you
did you ever regret it did you ever
think you know maybe i should have stuck
around yeah yeah
i'd go now if they would take me and for
another one i'd go on a heartbeat
i mentioned in
my
i think part of my first remarks
uh uh about the
bazooka
in that same in that same battle
uh of course i was i was
the company leader at that time how old
are you then how old was i i don't know
how do you know
uh i just don't talk about it age
29. no i'm 88. i went on 88 so i'm just
a kid wow we had kids younger than me
and so
when
after i
initially came
a little bit out of the adlen that i had
gone through
they had
they had the platoon leaders
and and and
the boys including my medic
all stacked up
like wood
then from that
stupid mistake
and
it's it's absolutely unbelievable
and
but what can you do
well what do you do how do you recover
from seeing that and continue to go on
and continue to fight you either get
help and get counseling
or you push it aside for 60 odd years
like i did
and do it the hard way
quit trying to be macho
it it's not it's not wrong to ask for
help
it's absolutely not wrong guys for help
uh i
i carry with me
and i probably will until i die
you can't touch me when i'm asleep huh
if you want to wake me up you touch my
feet
i i
i this hasn't happened in in many many
years but just recently
my wife
did that and and
and i told her i said don't ever do that
don't ever do that i heard her feelings
and i i had to settle down and tell her
why i said i could have hurt you really
bad
you can't do that yeah so and of course
my family knows
you touch my feet to wake me up now i
will carry that until i die but that's
in me
that's 70 years later you still have
that reaction i still have that
in in the in the ptsd
you will also take to your grave you
don't get rid of that that never goes
away
you can help it
and there's no medication for it
counseling helps
if you go and get a good counselor and
let them listen to you
and explain
and and when i first started the
counseling the lady sat down and she
says
uh i'm not gonna keep you to a few
minutes because i want you to go home
and i want you to take a a
a yellow tablet and i want you to write
down the one thing
that you're most upset about
well i did that in in
and and uh
while i was doing that
it dawned on me that
those people are dead
those people probably died
30 years ago
the people that you were angry at yes
yes and here i am carrying a grudge
around wanting to hurt somebody
and they are already dead right so then
i go back to the counselor and she said
she said uh well how did things go i
said
i don't know but i just had a a
a great awakening and i told her and she
was excited about it
so i my duration with counseling is only
four months
wow
so i learned how to control the anger
and i have not learned how to care to
control the emotions
and emotion and anger is right close
together
and both of them are dangerous if you
can't process them
and i have found a way now that through
the ptsd i can process that
different than what i did before
how often do you think about it i don't
i don't ever think about it it's there i
mean it's just there all the time it's
on your brain it's 24 it's 24 7. it's uh
365.
you can't keep from thinking about it
have you had a similar experience
you never forget
very often you'll hear
from people who have traumatic
experiences they'll say
well time will heal the wounds and don't
worry after time but what well and
perhaps it can improve somewhat but what
you are describing is this war that took
place 70 years ago
is still with you well i i sleep with it
and i i spend my days with it
it will never leave me
yeah number one
and i and i believe this firmly
i don't believe god created you to fight
wars
i know in the old testament listen i'm
verse i'm versed with all 66 books
i i've
i've read them many times and i've
preached on them for years and years
you
you can't undo some things once it's
happened to you
if i say i don't like you
there's nothing i can do about it and
nothing here and you can't take it back
yeah i can't i've already said that it's
said
the same way
with
ptsd
you don't know what happened that caused
it and you don't know what you don't
know
why you act or react
the like the way you do
i don't know why i'm hyper vigilant yeah
i i i
i don't know why
i have a a a disease that i'm gonna die
with
with
ptsd
even though it's not a disease it's
treated like a disease
but there's help that you can reduce it
you can reduce the anxiety you can
reduce
the um
the way you act the way you react i
should say
and uh so
yeah you can't say
uh
i i will go down and i will go to work
and i'll
bury myself in my work like i did and
i'll forget this message it won't mean
it won't mount to the hill of beans it
don't work like that
you know you have this very intense
experience when you're very very young
and then you get out and you've got your
whole career ahead of you and you've got
all your work life ahead of you
how does that formative experience shape
the way you treat work
i had
my experience with
dealing with people were different
i uh
being my size my weight
and i was on the boxing team for a while
i learned that was no way i want to earn
my living
but nevertheless
i stopped probably
200 fights
in in my lifetime
the last fight i stopped the guy killed
the other one shot him with a
nine millimeter
three bullets
letting his heart
and killed him
and uh
of course it was self-defense he hadn't
he had no choice but to do it
so
that was on tv and all of my children
call me and they know me
they say dad no more fights you can't
stop any more fights
so i stopped i had stopped that fight
three times
and blood splattered on me when he shot
him
it was a fight that just broke out in
yeah
it's stupidity
stupidity
but you but you felt an impulse if if
people were well i just need to stop it
they don't need to go any further
i've walked between two people with
their knives pulled out
uh i didn't feel any danger i didn't see
any danger to it
i didn't feel they would hurt me
yeah
the problem was with each other
yeah i mean i didn't i didn't and of
course i know that was not really
intelligent thinking on my part it's
courageous or reckless either the line
sometimes is a little thin yeah
i mean i i think i know the answer to
this but how do you think
the service and the war made you a
better man
made me appreciate
life in general
don't take anything for
granted father always said the fair
day's work for fair day's pay
your country needs you
you go
that's what he's not talking about
don't
stand in the line looking for a handout
the way this bunch is today yeah
that was a line that's a bad feature
today we don't have these kids trying to
help the country they're out there with
their hand out thinking come on you
you owe me what the hell i owe you yeah
that's the line from kennedy ask not
what your country can do for you but
what you can do for your country yep
just as the
uh
talks in 61 begin to
come about of a cease-fire
colonel kelly called me and
battalion commander
and
he
told me he said i want you to go
from here back to fort benning georgia
because
we want you to go to officer school
and i uh
thanked him
of course
before i ever left
for korea
i applied for back in those days i had
on-the-job training
and they would train you and it took
like five years of college
on the job training for five years
well i applied for that
well then being smarter than i was knew
that i was going to get drafted back to
korea
well it wasn't two months i was already
in korea
but as soon as i got back i went down
there and they put me away
so i went through that five years of
schooling
and it disappointed him because
um
i don't say i did a good job with the
company
i did the best i knew how
i was probably
as old as anybody in there yeah
and
we all got along good and and just at
that time
was uh when truman desegregated
the military
and then that all changed while while we
was in
korea but it it didn't affect anybody
anyway
i i don't think that there was any
fights broke out or anything
i mean to my knowledge yeah
yeah that was not a that was not a major
issue in your experience it was not it
was not because
listen i worked with the uh
african-american people all of my life
so i mean i
i'm a country boy i
they play baseball just like i do and
swimming is the same swimming hole i
swear to men
hey
i don't i don't look at it the way a lot
of people look at it now
you take a man that won't work for his
living i don't have any respect for him
right i don't care what color he is
right
right yeah it's it's not not a racial
thing it's a uh
it's not a natural thing a fact right
back right yeah
let's see when i went they should be
down to south carolina fort jackson's
out of a bit of a police
and i was in the dixie 31st century the
dixie division
so you was then fort jackson whenever
they segregated oh
yeah here they're
i don't know how many thousand of us in
the field
lined up
and i'll never forget it
this rebel bastard walked in the line
going out
out
if you weren't pure or white out hell
i realized three of my buddies were from
hogan's were indian boys yeah
out
oh yeah
i know our race i know that's when i
learned what racism was wow i learned in
there because i never knew the bigger
division that i'm hearing from you dale
is uh north and south north
i didn't even know there was a north i
was 20 years old
the country ended at the mason dixon
forget the 38th parallel we're talking
about the mason-dixon line
in the korean war when we got the
the mexicans the puerto ricans
who all ever was involved in it
uh when we got them in uh
dealing amongst them they bled and died
just like the rest of them
there was really no difference in us
we was we was there trying to survive
and i'm going to give you another uh a
bit of information about the
ptsd
and and
every g either
whether he realizes it or not went
through this
when you go in the into that thing
i don't care who you are you're you're
afraid you're you're
you you know there's a very good
possibility that you're going to get
killed
all right
then you have to you have to get out of
that mode
and you have to go into survival mode
[Music]
and then
it's your job to
be vigilant and that's why you're hyper
vigilant
and and it's your job to keep yourself
safe
if if you can get behind something don't
be a fool get behind something if
there's a hole to get in and get into a
hole
it doesn't never deep enough either
yeah
because the bullet will the bullet
doesn't see any color
whether you're mexican or whether you're
puerto rican or whether you're white
you're dead just the same
and that is probably what kept
a lot of them alive that they went into
that
survival mode
and like you said the bullet
doesn't disappear it's color race or
creed yeah you know the the leadership
of the military got in trouble about a
year ago
the leadership has gone political it's
gotten very and it's gotten very
seems like radical left i mean you're
seeing this see leadership is not like
what him and i was in the general of the
general the captain or the captain today
they're all political they're looking
for a way how to advance themselves and
it's strictly political do you do you
fear for the
national security and you know given how
politicized military position
my take on that is we have got a
generation
that half of no no whether they're a
girl or boy yeah there you go
and the other half don't know which
bathroom to use because i don't know how
they're bore alcohol yeah
uh
i would think that if we got in a real
conflict
the united states would be in trouble
now they would have to have
older people
drafted into the military if they're
going to ever win read anything well it
is amazing to think you both go into the
service at such a young age and
immediately you're going overseas
today we have a kind of delayed
maturation you're on your parents health
insurance until 26 you don't get a job
until later on you know maybe you're
waiting a year or two after college
there's just a you don't you don't move
out you don't get married you don't you
just don't grow up
you can't fight a war with people that
don't know how to
do anything yeah yeah you you do need
some kind of
hard skills uh
eagerness to go out
well you go into war
and and if you think those people won't
choose to you get out there and open
you'll find out right they will shoot
you yeah
and
it
it really puts microaggressions into uh
perspective
they're used to playing these video
games and blowing things up well that
doesn't work that won't work
you don't get to restart in the in real
life right well i would i wouldn't take
anything from my experiences in life
all of it
i've had good experiences i've had some
bad experiences but sometimes you have
to take the good with the bad
i i wouldn't want to go back to korea
i wouldn't want to go back to germany i
was grandson serving in germany now he
and his family is a bomb holder in in
germany
i wouldn't want to go back over there
i'm i'm at home now yep i'm at home
and and where i don't whether i'm safe
or not i don't know but i'm home right
in in in the korean war is
is i'm sure if you sit here for hours
and
pump me with questions i probably could
remember a lot that i have not said
but i'm also uh
my wife says i'm 92 years old
and my mind is not who it used to be
seemed pretty lucid to me yeah so there
there's where i sit
uh i'm happy where i'm at
i
i love my neighbors i love my community
uh
and now you're sitting here giving a
two-hour interview
about a war 70 years ago recalling
that's incredible
yes
well god's good
god is good
i i
i don't know how much longer i'm going
to live
but i'm gonna live happy
i'm not gonna go around be looking on
the ground i might be looking at wow
there's nothing down there for me
no
do you have any advice if you had to go
back now talk to that 17 year old kid
who gets his dad's signature to go
enlist
and say hey here's something that i
really wish i knew
when i was 17 18 years old
is there is there anything you would
tell that guy well like i said i just
got out of high school
graduated in june
december i turned 17 and
joined up
because i was missing out on something
you wouldn't change anything about it
you wouldn't give different advice wow
no i wouldn't
i wouldn't want my kids my s
if i had a son i wouldn't want him to
join the specific idea of going into
combat naturally no
but
but for you you could but uh
my son or daughter if they want to go in
learn a trade in the service better the
country yes i'm ready to go for it
i look at life a little bit different
but on the same subject
i believe
that
when my country calls for me
that i should answer
and the
oath that i took
it's perpetual
it never ends
and i believe that i'm patriotic enough
that today
if something happened broke out and i
you would give me the m1 i had
i would stand inspired until i fell
that's the way i feel about my country
i love my country
and i have no doubt that you would
you would be able to fire that gun for a
pretty pretty long time that's a that's
an incredible amount of uh
it's like he said
if our country called and needed us we'd
go on a heartbeat
well my country has been good to me
and um
i've lived in freedom all of my life
nobody's ever told me what i had to do
or what i couldn't do
i did basically what i wanted to or what
i could afford to do
and i've lived a very happy life
and to me i have really
tried my best to forget the korean war
which i find is impossible to do that
i
didn't have any um
unusual
experiences in germany i went to school
all the time i was there because i was
one of those unfortunate poor kids that
didn't get enough education
and then i come home from korea and i go
out go to school five more years
and then i get done with that and then i
enrolled in college and so
here i am
i tell you as you as you say you know if
your country called on you today you'd
pick up the same gun if if you told me
michael to defend you and your country
you've either got to rely on
30-something millennials
or gw and dale
at or around the age of 90. that would
not be a difficult choice for me i would
say absolutely
gw and and uh dale every day and that uh
that that is that is some incredible
fortitude guys gentlemen
thank you for your patriotism thank you
for your service and selfishly
thank you for making the trek to the
studio and uh
telling me and telling all of us a
little bit about this war that is so
often forgotten thank you both so much
dale well i thank you for the
opportunity thank you for the
opportunity